this is the it was phenomenal watching
number one watching you and daniel
together in this man like such a
beautiful
combination of actors on screen
you know some of my favorite parts were
really just like the beach themes that
that was fun can you tell me about that
day what that was like that day shooting
that
it was like it was actually the last day
that i that i shot and it was
kind of um
emblematic of the whole experience which
was that everybody was it was an
environment where everybody could like
have fun and kind of try stuff it was a
little improvisational which most of the
movie actually wasn't but
in that sense george wanted us to kind
of experiment have fun
he had created this familial environment
and
um despite the fact that it was february
it was like you know people don't really
swim in the ocean in february george
because you get hypothermia and die we
were all willing to do it for george
because uh he was so invested and so
wanted the movie to be good and we
wanted to be good for him and to be good
for him and um and a part of it was like
seeing how game and excited daniel was
just made me feel like
you know it's like what he kind of
represented to me throughout the movie
is i love the kid he's sweet and good
and a wonderful actor but more
importantly just such a great
person and um and he's kind of got he's
allows things to just kind of roll off
be what they are he's got this simple
beautiful talent and this is fun to be
around and and the fact that he was
having fun
it was freezing cold i thought i was
gonna die of hypothermia made me think
you know what i should be more like this
kid
i like that yeah that's good
you know we got to see some footage of
you and uh you and george on the
softball field there
uh how is he behind the bat how is how
is he he's good you know george was good
was also a pro baseball player like
among his many talents is that he's
really he's a jock i mean he's a he's a
very
he can hit and like i'm like dude drew
60. you shouldn't be stroking the ball
like you know getting it out of the park
oh it's making everybody look bad you
know what i mean he uh he wanted to get
up there don't have any doubt about it
he was like i'm going to show the cast
and crew you know what the director can
do and watch me launch a few and then
everybody had a little more respect for
him but he's uh he's great he's he's
wonderfully self-effacing and he also
has
uh no shortage of of you know talents
hidden in otherwise
absolutely you know i think everybody
needs an uncle charlie
and um i i even personally for me i was
taking notes when i was watching uncle
charlie give out advice and give out his
rules for you know living a good life
for you what are the rules that you've
gotta you gotta live by when you when
you wanna be a good person
uh you know it's true it seemed it seems
like uh uh i remember as you know being
a young guy and thinking about it
seeming kind of complex or difficult or
unknowable and it's gotten simpler you
know as i've gotten older because it
just involves like
kindness and forgiveness and at both for
oneself and for others and
you and really
you know ultimately i discovered for me
my life would largely be defined by
the degree to which i'm able to express
that that love and be present with my
children and that the rest of my life is
there are other things that are very
important in my life but that that is
the central preoccupation and and and
job that i have in life and it's it's
beautiful and it's wonderful and it kind
of allow other stuff that used to seem
harder or complicated or pretty i would
probably get preoccupied with sort of
fades away you know and it becomes about
because when you think of yourself as
how am i modeling a way to live so that
the my kids who watch me sort of get an
idea of how to navigate life but it was
very easy to just you know look i have
to be honest i have to tell the truth
and the sen and to tell the truth to
myself about myself and to want to keep
growing and
live with that integrity and and
you know that's kind of about it don't
hurt anybody you know help people
uh it's not that complicated at the end
of the day and work hard you have to
work hard at whatever you do and you
have to desire to improve always
otherwise you'll kind of get stuck at
whatever place you are
and don't be afraid of getting
hypothermia if george asks you and if
george clooney tells you to get in the
ocean get in the ocean okay in the ocean
right on man thank you so much for your
time
all righty take care